I was like well in New York I you know I
had a biking in and I tore it all in the
game and play lights out he's like what
we need to do that Santana Moss what's
up baby
except my brothers are you doing babe
hey Liv I'm good how are you I can't
complain I can't complain now people
know you for your football play what
about your pool play man so I got some
table in your house you can't say you
don't know how to play exactly this
might not be a pro let's see what you
can do got a stick right there for you
don't have a break for us hey one of
these white ball went over that so in
2005 you're in Washington what was your
relationship like with Dan Schneider and
what stories you have a Dan Schneider
the relationship was there you know one
of the things I learned early he loved
all these guys but he was the guy laid
on the line for him he really loved and
I remember oh seven tell me whatever you
know I'm sitting in the training room
banged up he'll after playing the Jets
playing my old team and never seen Dan
Snyder in the training room ever in my
life since I've been at risk in and he
walks down and like you you plant his
feet and you know what week it was
Cowboys be well it's the possibility I
can't be out there I got a seeing
something wanna work he's not what you
need I was like well in New York I you
know I had a Viking in and tore it all
in the game and play a lifestyle he's
like what we need to do that he like
miss these days of practice and Friday
be gonna try so Friday comes and they
cut my shoe out but make sure I can fit
my foot in them because the heel is just
so sore and big I can't put nothing on
it and I take my spat my shoe up I fed
it to my foot so I can keep the shoe on
and I go out there Friday um probably
fifty percent but it's Friday Friday
Friday Pettis is like a modified
walkthrough which is not but you want to
get a good sweat and you already told me
you talked to Fortis Brown DC now that
we've done plan we talked about these
these hynny games we don't have this
famous shot game here
you know it was just as we had one of
those games like man I got to go ball
out Cheers
and we out that game going to the
Cowboys I had to do more than a shot I
remember going to the game so paranoid
let me just go ahead and drink a little
more
how much is more normally what I would
do and what we was doing we had a shot
this particular game I literally took my
Gatorade but I finished drinking and
getting ready went into my book bag and
I had my always had a little hindi it
was probably like a person VSOP you
can't just say Hindi without sending the
VSOP burgers you had a had that one that
had to look up with mm-hmm open it and I
poured it into my Gatorade bottle how
much Hennessy filled it about halfway to
me halfway was too much and I didn't
think that I would drink that much but
my but time I got to the locker room
it was almost almost on wow I get out
get on the field and I didn't take the
bike in orderto at all yet and I'm
bouncing on this doggone mean cowboy
field I'm just and Dan out there early
you know how you feeling I'm ready to go
but they don't know why I play like this
they think it's a total on the bike it
took the first bus you know before
everybody else so I can't really test
this heel out it's not a second Buster
Buster got there all these guys they see
me in lockers they like oh ten of man
backs
you got 89 as I get out there to go out
there with the team that feeling I had
before it on wall so I'm like I need
this throw at all and this dog on you
know bike it in so every you drank half
a bottle of Hennessy no you drank half
had a Gatorade bottle of Hennessy yeah
and then you took vicodin toradol so the
Viking and turtle came after I realized
that the hill wasn't gonna hold up the
whole four quarters I'm already starting
to feel the effects of it getting ready
to go back in there before we come out
you know for the coin toss the feeling
that I had pregame before them there's a
pain kicked in it's on me out so much
like I literally heard a pin drop in the
nosebleed I was in a zone and I knew I
was like this can you be trouble for me
or trouble for the opposing
the line up in front of me so ended up
happening so that game was like like no
other man I ended up having one of the
better games of my career against the
Cowboys rather had 107 yards a touchdown
and this was being removed from two
weeks prior I didn't play in the two
games prior and had a chance to win the
game at the end again if Jason bring
that bar down a little bit Laura I'm
catching the post in the back of the end
zone to beat these guys again in the
last play but it didn't work out that
way but I end up not getting laid on the
line for the team and the owner what a
Dan Schneider said you have to play that
guy he just knew it was the DA he didn't
he didn't know nothing about what
transpired before the toreador in the
Vicodin but he like I appreciated that
like man you know what that that was
bigger and leaving that game you know
everybody appreciated me a little more
like tenant man you were not there took
me for the team and we appreciate you
for that especially their own
what do you thoughts on toradol I feel
about using that and now that you know
the effects of this what do you think
about still I still not 100% sure the
effects but I know that it was guys that
had a lot to say about it that that was
a reason or they was addictive to it and
that's was some of the reasons why they
was fighting to kind of band it it's
crazy because by the last four or five
seasons of my career that was taken away
so hey Mike I couldn't play without it
oh now I have to play without it it was
taken away so you know one of the things
I say about this game we walk into this
game knowing what some of the things
that we want to deal with whether this
is gonna be the rest of our lives or
just for that moment and so I felt like
some of the stuff comes with the game so
we got to just suck it up and whatever
allows us to play the game as long as
it's not illegal you got to do what you
do man you nice bro
gotta know something you better bust my
ass right now hey thanks for kicking it
with us subscribe to be our to check out
more dope videos like this one